Hello. I am David Kaplan and I am not an expert.
But I hope in this series to learn as much
as possible and explain it to you the best
way I can.
What happens when you fall into a black hole? We do not know. If you believe
Einstein's theory of relativity, we do know.
The person falling into the black hole crosses
the horizon of the black hole. And if the
black hole is big enough, the person doesn't
notice. They just keep on going. And if they
get close enough to the singularity at the
center of the black hole, bad things happen
to their body. They get stretched out, warped,
and gravity is so strong that it's very bad.
So we do have a description in that theory.
On the other hand, in quantum mechanics, if
you have a situation where there's a horizon
— a surface where nothing can come out from
behind it — then quantum fluctuations at
that horizon produce radiation and the radiation
comes out. And you could measure that, in
principle. But if that energy is coming out
of the black hole, even from just the horizon,
the black hole should shrink and eventually
disappear. And whatever had fallen into the
black hole essentially disappears. And the
confusing thing is that quantum mechanics
doesn't predict the disappearance of any information.
And so we would like to understand how the
information that went into the black hole
comes back out. And that requires describing
the inside of a black hole. But that means
that the theory of general relativity, which
predicts nothing interesting happening at
the horizon, smells like it's in contraction
with the theory of quantum mechanics, which
suggests that the horizon is a very important
place. So there's no complete description
of the interior of the black hole, which means
we don't know what happens. We don't really
care about what happens to somebody who falls
in. What we care about is attempting to describe
quantum mechanics and general relativity in
the same theory, and a black hole is the perfect
place because it requires both.